[Music]
[Applause]
marv albert will join us in an hour from
now the greatest catcher in baseball
history
in my opinion johnny bench joining us on
the program
uh we got a little spirited there in the
last uh
segment there with the what was going on
with the white sox and
uh the rookie player uh your mean
mercedes
uh they swings on a three-o pitch you
got a positional player in there it's
15-4
it's the ninth inning let me start there
these
damn unwritten rules of baseball john so
what are you supposed to do if you're at
the play now let me
let me at least say that tony larussa
said to his rookie
to take the pitch so i have a problem
that he disregarded tony la russo
but the the situation itself
3-0 positional player 47 mile an hour
ifa's pitch and it's 15 to four
what would you have done dan i mean
really i would have what
you have done the guy threw four pitches
in 26 seconds
who's going to look at a coach all right
let's just call the game all right we
got the mercy rule
let's just cancel the game okay they're
ahead they got to bring in some so we
forfeit
let's just go ahead and quit i mean the
guy you know the guys up there
he's trying to pad his stats it doesn't
there's no rules anymore
i mean those things are doing if tony
gave a mistake and it's just a simple
you know
i don't i don't think how much any
managers heads in the game at the time
except he knows 3-0 that somebody
shouldn't be swinging necessarily would
you have swung though john
probably but if i you know i thought he
got a tape sign obviously not
back in those days i doubt it i would
have probably looked in the dugout and
sparky would have went
pick one but alex grandma's down at
third base he would have been fine he
would have flashed the sign
and though so you know he hits a home
run on his next pitch which is now it's
three and one so is that a bad time
so are we just are we just saying okay
remember when
to teach did this i mean i think we just
got over this one another time and
and it was doing this and it's just it's
just now like you know the young kids
not whatever and
and whether he's going to look for a
sign at this point i
i don't i'm i'm not i don't have
anything a problem with it
but i do have a problem with him you
know throwing at the guy
you know in the game and yeah but tony
said hey it's okay i mean basically he
gave the opposition the green light to
throw
at his player the next game because he
said there's gonna be crossing
yeah yeah you know it was coming
everybody knew it was coming everybody
in the world knew it was coming
you know but the kid gets kicked out of
the pitcher gets kicked out of the game
and uh you know it's i mean the kid was
pitching a great game too
but you know he's on it's sort of like
everybody's watching you in the dugout
waiting for you to do it
who do we do what time do we do it when
do we pick the guy
who is the guy let's get this guy and if
it was going to be a problem then
tony could have held him out of the
lineup and uh
but i think you've also wanted to prove
a point to
uh the kids saying hey if you do this
you know you got to face the
consequences and this is probably what's
going to happen
yeah but he didn't throw it at his head
he threw it behind his back down his
legs and everything else so
yeah but tony can't be making this
public like why don't you
tony's a hall of fame manager why don't
you just say look we're going to keep it
in-house we're going to talk about this
it's a learning experience he's a rookie
he's talented
he's basically saying hey you know he's
got to understand this there's going to
be consequences
i'm sure they're in the clubhouse our
clubhouse leaders supposedly
quote unquote leaders are saying hey you
better expect what's coming okay
you made a mistake you did the wrong
thing and the kids saying well i got a
chance to hit a three-run homer
i've got three more rbis on my list i go
into arbitration next year
i'm going in arbitration and my guy says
well you know you have 97 rbis
uh oh that's right you ate that three
round homework we're not going to count
that
we're not going to count that today do
you think that players really care
about that they're embarrassed to be no
hit in today's game oh gosh
yes i don't i don't think so
because these guys nobody puts the ball
in play they're all swinging for a home
run
dan you're a basketball player okay
you're a basketball player and golfer
you don't
you know i mean hey come on
and we were in the eighth inning and i
came in and joe morgan gave me the
biggest hug in the world
because the one thing he didn't want to
be was no hit we got no hit once
twice one year by s guy rick wise rick
sunny wise and he hit totally he hit two
home runs i was at the game
[Music]
and did you i was there at the kenny
holtzman no hitter
well i think i remember for some reason
you're being there because i heard you
saying
for god's sake johnny but and you and
you
did in the seventh inning you tried to
bun
am i right yes you tried to
bunt and frizzy has a problem with
trying to bunt to ruin a no-hitter go
ahead fritzy say it to johnny oh he is
he is he's
in the dog i just think that that's
that's something there's a way that it
could be even worse
no you have to stick your you have to
turn around and square around and bunt
you're admitting the only chance we have
of getting on base
is to just stick the bat out that we
can't just no no you said it was
weak and tell johnny that he was i loved
and it's i'm don't try that don't work
don't work that angle all right i'm
disappointed what happens
what happens now if i drop a bun we get
a base hit
and now all of a sudden this guy is so
rattled the flood gates open
and we win the game or that's the only
hit of the game and you ruined the no
hits what happened with your pitching
pretzy
if i was if you were pitching and i
butted on you i would be so angry
yeah you'd pick try to pick me off and
hit me yeah you would have picked off
you wouldn't even throw them to the
first place when you just hit me in the
leg or something
you'd like to guard your mound right now
wouldn't you johnny if fritzy's on the
mountain you would charge
me you know fritzy's been good to me
he's never sent me a gift for all these
times i've been on and everything
i get nothing from this wow all i get is
fritz he's got an idea
you know you got a great microphone keep
it you know it's it's what you do best
thank you no not not not really
not really but i told you i was at i was
at the game when johnny tried to bunt to
ruin ken holden
i was hoping you were wrong and that he
wouldn't stick the bat out to try to
ruin it because you think that johnny is
weak and soft that he would do that to
try to
johnny specifically that particular plan
yeah
that was weak and so johnny was weak
by doing that and i said you today's
player i don't think is
as concerned about getting no hit just
like they don't care about striking out
200 times
back then you didn't want to strike out
and you certainly didn't want somebody
to no hit you
no no it no no because then the next day
fritz he says you believe that brett's
got no hips last night
right mike todd yeah i i'm disappointed
you're disappointed
what's what's the consensus on the other
dance yes mclovin it's just so
unfamiliar to me because i'm a phillies
fan like mike schmidt would never even
consider bunning so i don't even wow not
even
my wheel i wouldn't think about it
i'm gonna tell mike and michael be proud
you said that but mike would have
dropped down a bun every now and then
yeah
yeah and philly fans would still be
upset with schmidt if he even tried to
do no matter what schmidt he did philly
fans didn't
didn't like him right does he get more
mail when he keeps saying i'm a phillies
fan
you know i mean he has to say you know
but you're a rookie here in 68 would you
have
would you have swung on a 3-0 pitch
oh yeah you mean that no if you were
told not to
no no no okay oh no no no no no 68 dave
bristol
dave bristol would have find me a
hundred dollars and never have my you
know my weak salary
but they lowered the they changed the
amount after 68. how
how much of an advantage was it for the
pitchers that year
well they dropped it down by what one or
two inches i think it was and gibson had
just had that one one two era
and they're saying we've got to get more
offense in and that's when the american
league decided to go to the designated
hitter
and now it's like everybo is a bomb and
you know
and you know my buddy mike zanino you
know they're talking about him you know
either
walk strike out or hit a home run and
you know because these guys and there is
no consequence
i mean i see guys i look at the lineup
these guys are hitting 159
167. how are they in the lineup
i mean in in these days it's fine in our
day
because you know they have the earl
weaver mentality of it the three-run
homer
let's get that going on the board but in
our day
you were hitting anywhere close to 220
you were looking over your
you know hoping when you got to the park
your locker was still that little
uniform in it
but they don't even have a mendoza line
now because mendoza is actually a decent
hitter in today's game john
the 200 line yes i was talking to you i
was talking to euchre the other day
because he's got a lifetime i think 200
or 206 or whatever it is but
now we laugh about it and everything
else but no no there's nothing out there
anymore that says mendoza or anything
else
200. the barrier i mean we had lee mae
tony perez and i
and we had if whoever struck out a
hundred times
first and we were trying everything to
keep from doing that
had to buy the other guy bottles of
champagne i mean that's
you know we were serious about not
reaching that hundred we've got a guy
how many now probably has 100 strikeouts
already is gallow up there close
he might be do you realize how far
earl weaver would be great in today's
baseball
from the standpoint of hey go up there
and hit a three-run homer
that's all that's all butch i mean you
know we had a guy named don hefner was
the manager
he called everybody butch and he would
sit that three-month homer man
and earl would sit back there and wait
for somebody to do it and of course i
think somebody was talking
about you know you put a three runs on
the board with that oriole staff
you're probably going to have a winner
and in those days you know
palmer had 20 and cuellar and mcnally
and
bad dobson you know just you know they
had the pitching to do it and you can
play for that one swing that would
bring you a win offense was offense
do you ever talk to brooks robinson
about that 1970 world series where
he he he caught everything and then
caught things that
even you know what didn't seem humanly
possible
we laugh every time i still want my
hiccup belt award
i want it back i want it back he's
robbed me he robbed me
it got him good john he was he was
unbelievable like
imagine a fielder changing the
complexion of an entire world series
yeah in 1971 in the all-star game i hit
a bullet down
down there and he caught it just like it
was nothing again and i threw up my arms
and i threw my arms like that as i'm
running to first base and he's laughing
all the way as he's throwing it to first
it was it was just amazing and you know
the thing the way he did it he didn't do
it with any show or anything else
he and the vacuum cleaner you know and
there were other great third basemans
you mentioned schmidty with smitty was
about as good as they got a third as
well
and today you watch these guys and
they're acrobats aronado
and chapman and guys that are just
phenomenal i mean
you know you want to look at averages
you know dan
back in our days you you had these guys
running the outfield
but these guys are running nine five
hundreds out there in the outfield
they're catching everything they're
jumping over fences
they are such athletes today i i can't
imagine anybody ever hitting 400 again i
think the new line is probably 350 or
360.
it's just these guys in the infield
they're stealing base hits
left and right i mean they're playing so
deep they got the coverage they do that
they're acrobatic
they steal balls down the line they
throw the ball across the infield and a
bullet
i mean the watch today's athletes it's
just totally incredible to me to see the
talents that they have
and a lot of that was done with ozzy
ozzy became one of the leaders of
you know being such an unbelievable
fielder
and then they followed with vasquel and
they followed with guys that could do
all this stuff
i mean ozzy gets a lot of the credit but
these guys are taking so much pride in
their defense
that they become just a game changer
every time you look up
great to talk to you sorry that fritz
sure called you weak and soft
um but it's always great to talk to you
richie you got my address buddy you
better start sending some gifts
wow i'm on the couch wow that's the
great johnny
this is making up yeah thanks dad fritz
he called him out called him weak